- As promised earlier in this show,
vision board maker expert
Ron Funches has returned
to help us make a vision
board for America,
because let's be honest,
we could use a little vision
or better vision at that, (Ron laughs)
ain't it funny that its 2020,
and I'm saying a better vision, its funny
so Ron, has it been harder for you
to find humor these days
- A little bit, it depends on the day?
And I think that's what we have
to give ourselves as human beings,
it's okay to feel down,
it's okay to feel sad,
it's okay to feel angry,
but then it's also okay to feel happy
and enjoy your friends
and the people around you
and keep your happiness,
I think that's something
I've been really focusing on.
- Well Ron it looks like
you have a nice set up there
so is that a felt board?
- Yeah, I've been upgrading.
- Lemme, lemme upgrade you.
(both laughing)
That's awesome, okay so let's
build the board together,
what do you have to put
on it? What's on it?
- Okay well, we start with something,
some things are new
and some things say the same,
The Rock boom, right in the middle.
(Kelly laughs)
He's still there, 'cause
I think he's needed now
more than ever.
- I know, no hell I'd vote
for him at this point.
(both laughing)
- Absolutely and also I wanna
work with him on a new TV show
he's making, if he watches this show.
- This looks good together (Ron laughs)
I think that this is
yes, it's gonna happen,
so what's next?
- But like you said, we gotta
voting ballot right there
because we gotta vote,
we gotta vote things are going ways that,
no matter what you feel change is needed,
we need some sensibility
we've gotta get out there and vote,
you gotta let your voice be heard.
- Amen, yeah.
- I got a mask here because you've
gotta wear that mask .
- Yes.
- Some people are not wearing masks
and they got to, they got to,
my mom lives in Phoenix, Arizona,
and she says, she goes out shopping
and nobody's wearing that mask
and I get worried about her,
so please wear your mask.
- It's just kind, yep.
- It's just kindness.
- And it's smart, so what's next?
- Okay, we got a Statue of Liberty
because we gotta have liberty
and I think right now this is something
that we need to remember is
our ideals, our principle,
what this country was founded on,
and just remember where we came from
just so we can get to where we need to go
I think that's important.
- Absolutely, okay what's next?
- I got my own private island
because I need one.
(both laughing)
- Maybe we can all go there,
if everything goes to crap. (Kelly laughs)
- You're welcome, Kelly,
you are most definitely
welcome on my private island.
- Alright, what's next?
- We got a Black Lives Matter sign
'cause I just think that's important
for everyone to remember,
it's not about separation,
it's about togetherness
and that when one group is under attack,
all our liberties are under attack
and we have to protect each other
and remember that Black Lives Matter,
especially for me as being
a father of a black son
and a black son who has autism
and it scares me often about
what could happen to him
so I just want everyone to remember that.
- Yes, amen yes, what's next?
- We got Kit Kat bar.
(both laughing)
- Is that for the munchies
or 'cause we need a break?
(Kelly laughs)
- We need a break and also the munchies
and also, when you out there
and doing all this voting
and protesting and stuff,
you get a little hungry.
You need to (Ron laughs)
you need to take a break.
- Or snack.
- Yes.
- I love it, I love it,
okay wait, what else?
- And then last but not least,
I have a nice little barbecue grill here
'cause I figured out that we vote
after we get everything together
after we come back together,
let's get together eat
grill up some barbecue,
if you're vegan we can
put some portobellos
on a whole different grill for you.
- Like giant pot luck for America.(laughs)
- Absolutely, that's what we need Kelly.
- I know everything can be
solved with food, I think.
(both laughing)
- You're a woman after my own heart.
- I love that.
Anyway thank you so much Ron,
it's always good to see you, man
you're so like just a breath of fresh air
you just make people happy
that's a very amazing
gift you have with that.
- Thank you very much, that's
a beautiful compliment,
thank you.
- Yes.